les pays bas tout comme le canada
d'ailleurs sont des champions de la
production industrielle de port mais ce
modèle soulève de plus en plus de
questions en trop pour des raisons
environnementales
oui le purin peut servir d'engrais métro
de purin devient une source de pollution
en misant sur la grande intelligence des
ports infirmier néerlandais propose une
solution qui pourrait révolutionner
l'élevage porcin
[Musique]
on
bîmes it to have de respecte bac nous
devons à nouveau respecté les cochons et
leurs erreurs et man speight de break
awang tout je veux donner plus de
liberté aux cochons le rendre la place
qui leur revient
ken cummings bonjour
qu'est se répète n'est pas un
agriculteur comme les autres sur sa
ferme dans le sud des pays bas il
révolutionne la façon d'élever les ports
à commencer par la nourriture qu'ils
leur donnent socatri tu peux voir ici
catherine à quel point nous les
néerlandais sommes civilisés
tout ça ce sont les aliments jetés par
la plus grande chaîne d'alimentation bio
aux pays-bas ses fruits et ses légumes
viennent d'aussi loin que la nouvelle
zélande et le costa rica
ils sont encore bons mais le
consommateur va trouver que cette pomme
par exemple à une petite hache de trop
et ne voudra pas l'acheter heureusement
que les cochons sont là comme nous ils
sont omnivores il mange de tout il y a
quelques années l'agriculteur a conclu
une entente avec une chaîne
d'alimentation qui lui livre chaque
semaine ses invendus une aubaine pour le
détaillant qui évite ainsi de payer pour
se débarrasser de ses déchets en mélange
avoir des poutres et la date de
péremption à neuf jours
je veux élever des cochons en évitant au
maximum le gaspillage alimentaire
tout ce que je leur donne ce sont des
résidus de la transformation ou des
aliments est vendu comme semestre
[Musique]
je suis infirmier de dix neuvième
génération ma famille est établie dans
ce village depuis le xiiie siècle
ce n'est pas facile dernier du
changement parce que les fermiers
certains systèmes et le système actuel
vise à produire du port toujours moins
cher
à la ferme l'heure du repas est toujours
un moment de découverte pour les animaux
c'est très important qu'ils trouvent du
plaisir en mangeant
c'est comme pour nous les humains si on
mangeait du pain matin midi et soir on
ne mourait pas mais on aurait pas de
plaisir aujourd'hui les cochons apprécié
ce que je leur donne des raisins du
melon et des laitues demain ce sera
peut-être des produits laitiers alors
ils ne savent jamais ce qu'ils auront et
il aime toujours être surpris comme nous
si castrés peines vit aujourd'hui de son
élevage de porcs il n'en a pas toujours
été ainsi
j'ai fait des études de médecine
vétérinaire à l'université du trech
mon doctorat portait sur le comportement
des ports il parcourt alors le monde
pour une firme spécialisée dans
l'élevage du porc mais à la fin des
années 90 sa carrière prend un tournant
décisif à l'époque une épidémie de
grippe porcine sévit en europe
[Musique]
j'ai dû euthanasier des porcelets qui
était en pleine santé parce qu'ils se
trouvaient dans des zones infectées j'en
ai eu en asie plus de 10000
le rôle d'un vétérinaire c'est de
soigner les animaux et de veiller à ce
qu'il demeure en santé alors je me suis
dit ça suffit je ne peux plus faire ça
je veux plutôt contribué à la bonne
santé des animaux et c'est ce que je
fais depuis et maintenant je veux aussi
les rendre heureux
sur sa firme il n'élève que 35 thuir
productrice qui auront chacune deux
portés par année les animaux sont élevés
dehors à longueur d'année dans de grands
enclos ce sont principalement des
banshee une race aujourd'hui menacé
la vente de la vie très prisé mais aussi
des mâles pur sang lui assure un revenu
sans modèle de ferme est à des années
lumières des porcheries standard aux
pays bas qui compte 3400 port en moyenne
la production porcine d'aujourd'hui est
basée sur la science d'il ya 25 ans
les bâtiments la manière d'élever les
cochons tout ça est pour le dire de
manière polie dépassé jc fait pour
favoriser la croissance rapide départ
mais ça ne répond pas vraiment à leurs
besoins
[Musique]
chez lui chaque cochon a beaucoup de
liberté
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'il dorme accès c'est aussi
ici dans cette ut que les porcelaines s
l'instinct naturel de la truie la pousse
à toujours chercher un endroit sombre et
couverts pour mettre bas
pas du tout il n'y a pas d' extrêmement
figurines parce que les porcelets sont
propres très rapidement dès le lendemain
de leur naissance ils vont sortir pour
aller uriner dehors voilà pourquoi il
n'y a pas d'odeur
et l'expression de leur comportement
naturel ne s'arrête pas là
luka bos fut hôte regardez ce champ on
dirait la belgique après la première
guerre mondiale avec les tranchées et
les bombardements
en ces semaines la truie a complètement
labouré cette parcelle certains trous
sont tellement profond que de caisse
peut y prendre place sans problème
chikhoune a explosé ici ce n'est qu une
truie using d'heure qui a creusé avec
son droit quand les cochons sont actifs
ils peuvent passer 50 % de leur temps à
fouiller le sol dans un bâtiment avec
des planchers en béton c'est impossible
qu'elle serait peines possède 10
hectares de terre et peut ainsi faire
des rotations de parcelles chaque année
mais tous les éleveurs ne peuvent pas
offrir autant d' espace à leurs animaux
lapret grande majorité des cochons sont
aujourd'hui élevé à l'intérieur pour
améliorer le bien-être de ces animaux là
il a donc mis au point un équipement
révolutionnaire qui mise sur les
habiletés cognitives des cochons
le port est le plus intelligent des
animaux en agriculture il est aussi
l'animal de ferme le plus propre qui
soit
sa solution est ni plus ni moins qu'une
toilette
[Musique]
j'ai inventé la toile est intelligent
pour cochons
j'utilise un bonbon citronnée pour
récompenser l'animal quand ils urinent
un endroit précis de l'enclos le but est
de remplacer les planchers traditionnel
des porcheries sous lesquels les
déjections liquides et solides se
mélangent il a donc créé deux espaces
distincts ou le cochon peut faire ses
besoins un urinoir est ce qu'il appelle
un pouvoir pour les excréments sous le
plancher de l'urinoir se trouve un
capteur lors de notre passage les
toilettes était en rénovation
[Musique]
quand de l'aude ou de lure into
le capteur la détecte actes
ce capteur est connecté à un système de
récompenses qui laisse alors tomber un
bon ton
oui et après un jour ou deux beaucoup de
cochon compris ok conjure initie j'ai
une récompense et c'est mieux curie née
dans le pouvoir parce que là je n'ai pas
de récompense
le taux de réussite quand les cochons
sont entraînés un à la fois en présence
d'un être humain atteint presque 100%
quand les cochons sont laissés seuls
avec la machine à bonbons le succès est
moins grand
environ 40% de laurine va se retrouver
ici ou les cochons sont récompensés par
un bonbon
le reste des pipis va être fait dans le
pouvoir donc il y a encore place à
l'amélioration
par contre il n'ya pas durini
d'extrêmement ailleurs dans l'enclos
donc les cochons reste propre tout comme
la paille et le boîtier pour améliorer
la performance des cochons qu'ils
collaborent notamment avec un
scientifique chinois associé à la plus
grande université agricoles des pays bas
le but du projet de recherche et
d'adapter la toile est intelligente
la réalité d'un élevage moderne on veut
essayer d'entraîner un groupe de cochon
pas seulement un animal à la fois et on
souhaite le faire avec un système
automatisé mais pourquoi vouloir tancé
par il urine des matières fécales et fut
donc si les excréments et l'uriné
n'entrent pas en contact ça ne produira
pas d'ammoniac l'ammoniac c'est ce qui
provoque l'odeur caractéristique qui
émane des porcheries réduire les
émissions d'ammoniac améliore la qualité
de l'air ambiant mais aussi le bien-être
des travailleurs et des cochons humaine
l'ammoniaque est un gaz très irritants
pour les muqueuses nasales mais aussi
pour la trachée et les poumons
ça rend les animaux plus sensibles aux
infections bactériennes ou virales donc
on doit éviter de loger les cochons au
dessus du lisier profondeur
notre objectif c'est que les toilettes
occupent moins de 10% de la surface de
l'enclos et qu on y récolte 95% des
matières fécales et de lure in comme ça
c'est plus facile à ramasser et ça
réduit beaucoup les émissions d'ammoniac
en plus l'engrais issue de la séparation
de l'uriné des excréments et de
meilleure qualité
je veux produire de façon plus durable
youth à faut qu'on utilise au mieux ces
engrais organiques au lieu des engrais
chimiques qui sont dommageables pour
notre climat
champion de la production industrielle
avec 12 millions de porcs sur un
minuscule territoire les pays-bas
n'exporte plus seulement la viande mais
sont désormais forcés d'exporter une
partie du purin vers des pays voisins
faute d' espaces pour les pendre le
modèle qui a fait le succès du pays
n'est plus viable nous sommes allés trop
loin
je sens que le ventre il faut faire de
la viande un produit de luxe et payer
les producteurs en conséquence
notre environnement ne peut pas soutenir
la production actuelle et les cochons
non plus car ce sont eux les victimes au
final
alors donné au port un système de
toilettes c'est vraiment contribuer au
bien-être animal à la ferme
[Musique]